Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn his time for the Monday
morning podcast from Monday. Uh,
June 25th, 2018 what's going on? Oh, whoa.
Yo, how you doing? How are you doing with
the summer? The summer's here, right?
We're in the, we're in the twenties
of June. Somewhere along the lines.
The first day of summer, you know, back
in the day you used to know it, right?
Because there wasn't as many channels
and you would watch the local news and
they'd bring it up. Today's the
first day of summer. Tell us, Jack,
what can people look forward to weather
wise? While I'll tell you a bike.
We got a low pressure system.
[inaudible] don't inflate those
fucking above ground pools. Yes. Yep.
Um, and then they'd laugh for no
reason. Your weekend's going to suck.
Um, anyways, uh, it's gotta be a
summertime, right? To fucking son's out.
There you go right there.
Global warming. Um,
what'd you do this weekend?
I have a couple of cores.
Like that's this generation's Budweiser.
Right? Cause like they're crushing it.
You know,
Peyton Manning's fucked up.
You notice the second Peyton
manning fucking bought Budweiser.
Now it's second place. You
know, you didn't buy it.
He bought into it the
second he fucking got it.
I bet he started pointing fingers
at everybody. You know, we, we, we,
we had some hops issues,
right. And all of a sudden,
nobody's getting along over there.
And of course life now cause lights ahead.
Right? I Bet Tom Brady invested in
course light. Sorry. Why would I do this?
I like Peyton manning now
that he's retired. You know,
I could look back and be like,
you know what?
That fellow was said quite a quarterback,
but when they're playing against your
team, you hate him. It's stupid. You know,
you don't hate them. You just
hate him. It's weird. Um,
anyways,
uh,
the summers here I am back
from vacay shawl and a,
I'm getting ready this weekend. Oh,
freckles. Shaking off the cobwebs.
I'm going to be in Minneapolis,
Minnesota, in Detroit,
Michigan. Okay. Couple, uh,
Joe, six pack towns. You know,
where they put their pets
on one leg at a thought. Uh,
looking forward to that and a,
so I'm going to be around
La doing a bunch of spots,
shaking off the dust among the
elliptical work enough to Crosol
panel shock a lot. I never
had any of those, you know,
my wife's into those
fucking things. I, I like,
I like the plain old
boring white guy croissant.
I don't need any flavor.
Uh,
anyways. Oh my God. Um,
I don't want to talk about this early on,
but I have to out of respect, uh, to sad,
sad, sad, sad day. Uh, the passing of
the Great Vinnie Paul,
um,
drummer of obviously Pantera damage
blend and hell yeah, good Lord.
What a, what a loss. Can't even,
can't even put it into words.
And I was lucky enough to meet him.
He was a big comedy fan and I
remember the first time I met him,
I was opening for the
late Great Charlie Murphy.
This is what happens when you get older.
Like half of your stories is like pap
the people in a moment like fucking dead.
It's sucks. Um, but anyways, yeah, me,
Charlie and don l or on tour.
And we did the Addison Improv
and, uh, I remember that that was one of
those shows, one of the few times I ever,
I went over without even realizing it.
I always knew when I was going over,
but I did like 40 minutes and
I was supposed to like 25.
It just one of those stages where
there was talking and I don't know what
happened and, um,
Charlie was cool with it,
but I was embarrassed
because I never do that shit.
And it's a real country thing to
do and it's something, you know,
makes the headliners job more difficult
because you ate up all of that extra
time where an amount and
all of that shit. So, uh,
I do remember that from that weekend,
but one of those shows,
it wasn't the show when
I went over, but, uh,
I was standing after
the show selling my cds.
This is how long ago this was. It
was right around, uh, was 2004.
His brother was still alive.
Um,
and I was just standing there
and I just looked up and he,
and he was standing right there.
Finney fucking Paul. And, you know,
it wasn't like he was Vinnie Paul
offstage. He just was Vinnie Paul.
He had the fucking cowboy hat on,
you know,
this shirt with flames on it and shit,
these crazy cowboy boots.
And he was just standing there with a big
smile on his face. And I was just like,
oh, I mean this guy, he's like, guys
saw on the cover of modern drummer.
I couldn't believe it. I was like, I was
like, Holy Shit, you fucking Vinny Foley.
He just started laughing and you know,
was super complimentary
about the show and all that.
And then he invited us out. Uh,
he had his own club out there,
gentleman's club,
then we all went out there
and he was nice enough,
I actually sat with him in
his club for like 45 minutes,
like a total drum nerd and asked
them all of these questions about,
um, drum parts that he
did. And, and, um, like,
who were the guys that he listened
to? And, uh, and you know,
I asked, I was like, you know,
who do you think only one
of the underrated drummers
out there? And he was like,
Oh, Alex van Halen, you know, and
we went, went on and on about him.
And it's kind of ironic because I really
feel that Vinnie and Dimebag worthy,
Eddie and Alex, I should say Alex and
Eddie of their generation. And um,
it just sucks man. He was just such
a nice guy. And then after that, uh,
he probably came out to two or
three other shows and he always was,
always was just the greatest,
nicest guy. And, um,
it's,
I don't know,
one of the reasons why I never got into
double bass playing was because so many
people, I just felt like once,
like they all live, fills,
everything was just the,
their fucking feet in their hands stunk.
And it didn't groove. It just was going
nine zillion miles an hour. And, you know,
it was impressive to look at,
but it didn't, it didn't give me,
the chills did make me want to do it.
And he was a guy that changed that.
And I,
when I listened to him play,
um, my younger brothers
who were independent, Tara,
I fucked up. I never saw
him. Um, a member, one of my
brothers went to go see him,
was telling me how amazing the show is.
But to be honest with you, like I, I just,
you know,
concerts with different,
back then you could get fucked up at
a concert and there was no cell phone
footage, you just got fucked up and that
was it. And there was like mosh pits.
Like it just, it had changed
and I got a little bit older.
I was in my mid twenties,
basically when they came around and I had
already started doing standup and shit.
And um, you know, I remember
going to a couple of, uh,
you know, concerts like ACDC and shit
and people were doing blow and it was,
you know, it was a little
fucking, you know, there was,
you had to be like a certain level of
fucked up just so you could stay relaxed
so you could kind of navigate it,
you know what I mean?
You couldn't be sitting there looking
fucking nervous. And I want, you know,
and that was just like ACTC,
which was always like a fun show.
So like put this pan, Tara came in, it
was a new level of aggression and anger.
Certainly, you know, with Phil singing,
I had never heard anything like that.
And um, you know, just the way I was just,
I just had this feeling my, I
was, I was too afraid I was,
I'm like fucking got to go down there,
my fucking orange hair trying to grow it
out and it just gets bigger and bigger
and it looked like Bernie from
room to 22 and there's a mosh pit,
I'm going to get the Sh,
you know how I always got over with people
was making them laugh and the show is
going to be too fucking loud.
So if they would just kind of look
at me the way I looked, I mean, I,
I just felt like it
wasn't going to go well.
So I was a fan from afar and I really
fucked up by not seeing those guys.
And um, I remember when Vinny came down
on the show, he said, hey, you know,
I got this, this new, uh, this new
band. I think it was. Yeah, it was,
it was damaged plan. He said would play in
New York. And he said, he goes, he goes,
I'll hook you up. I said,
really? He said, dude, he goes,
you can fucking stand right
behind me while I play the
whole show. And of course,
um, I had some fucking road
gig when they came to town.
I think Florentine went cause I remember
talking to him about it and I was so
fucking envious that he got
to go and I didn't get to go.
So I never saw him play
live. But, um, you know,
since doing that Dean del ratio or I had
to learn how to play a butcher the song
, but I tried to learn how to play
that song by Molly crew livewire,
which had the double bass, you know,
basic thing in there. Since then,
I've just kinda gotten addicted to it.
And I was listening to all of the pan
terrorists stuff in a whole nother like
level and um,
you know,
cowboys from Hell and fucking, um, um,
broken and this love,
just loving the,
the drum parts are just so
fucking perfect in all of those.
And I was just talking,
I was talking to my drum teacher
literally that day of how great, um,
Vinnie Paul was, um, with his work in
that band and, and then like, fuck,
it was so weird that night.
Then all of a sudden I got that text,
I couldn't fucking believe
it. And I'm Super Sad. But,
um,
I don't know.
Like the only good thing I could say is
the got the mark that the guy left his,
he, he won't be forgotten. And obviously
his brother hasn't been. So anyways,
that's my little,
my little point of view on a truly one
of the great artists that I ever heard of
or got to, I don't know, listen to
whatever hang out with or anything. So,
so that sucks. And that's sad. So I don't
know where the fuck to go from here.
How do you, how do you turn it
back to being funny? You know? Um,
can I talk about the Germans playing
the Swedes in the fucking, uh,
do they play Sweden? Is that
what it was at by the, the,
the shirts for the same colors if
flagged. So, um, I always fucked that up.
Sweden and Switzerland because
I'm an American and we never,
they never taught us geography like that.
And I remember one time I did a
Gig in Sweden and I said, hey,
it's great to be here in Switzerland.
And they all laughed thinking I was
joking and I honestly fucked it up and I
just rolled with it. I was just
like, Hey, just fucking with you.
They both start with sw, but I did
that the whole, thank you Cleveland.
Whatever the fuck it
was a spinal tap thing.
I gotta get back there.
I haven't done, um,
what would you call that? Hitler's ranch
up there. Norway, Sweden and Finland.
All those places when he used to look
across the was at the Baltic Sea.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
It's just looked across that water.
They're on disaster is what
people should look like. Yeah.
Frolicking in the garage. Um, anyways,
um, fellow swing, did
you know, they, they,
they were noncommittal a World War II
ended up being a great fucking move.
Not socially. It wasn't a good move, but
it was a great fucking move financially.
Cause just for the fact that they were
still standing after World War II and
never got bombed, you
know, let the, let the,
let the crowds fucking use their
trades that go into Norway. Um,
they stood there, they're
fucking Applebee's was
still open at the end of it,
you know? So, I mean, I, if I guess
you can learn something from Sweden
when,
when shit is hitting the fan and you
need to stand up and make a stand,
don't let other people do it.
Just kind of sit back and see who wins it.
Add a carry on.
Anyways, so the Swedes have
play in Germany. All right.
I'm mostly German,
so I usually root for Germany.
MMM.
But whatever. Or I just root for
an underdog like Iceland. I mean,
I ain't fucking roof Iceland and
Poland and shit like that. You know,
I'm rooting for all any anybody other
than the powerhouses that always seem to
be in and I don't know shit
about soccer, so this is, boy,
it's going to make it funny.
But anyway,
so I'm watching this fucking game
and this Swedish dude, right? Yeah.
He's on a fucking break away. Once
you going, God, he's all alone.
Right. And then there's Jay guy
in the German team, a black dude,
which is hilarious. You know what I
mean? I was always just sitting like,
like how conflicted would
Hitler be Germany one,
but the lots of foods is that outsell.
Um,
okay.
He comes down and goes to not
only went to like trip the guy,
he also cut,
like just pushed him from behind and
like a fucking referee and the WWE,
somehow this guy didn't see it. I mean, I,
I think it happened in the box,
in the painted area,
whatever the fuck they
call it in that sport.
And I think that that should've just
been one of those fucking penalty kicks
with a goalie.
Just dives and guesses one side.
Um, but anyways, the Swedes ended up going
up one nothing than Germans tied it up.
And then this guy, he did the old bend.
It like Beckham. You did the old fucking,
uh, around about there. I don't know
how to talk about the sport. Uh,
but I gotta tell you something.
I actually,
I love making fun of soccer, but I have
to watch it. No, didn't make fun of it.
And now having watched it,
I'm actually,
I kind of love it now and I kind of
understand the beauty of the game.
Finally.
I'm starting to get it.
And it is really cool that it is so
hard to score that when it happens that
people absolutely lose their
fucking minds. So I am on board.
I'm going to continue to make fun of it.
I had it on in the
background and you know,
I had like fucking two weeks a male
here that I was going through and um,
and I,
the amount of times that I just kept
looking over at the TV because he knows
he'd be like,
I already fucking, yeah. Oh,
oh,
he's going to be shit.
So I was sitting at the table
going like, oh my God, hey,
something almost happened. That's
what it just seemed like. Um,
okay.
But it really is a great game. Uh, GI
bill. Yeah. You really, uh, you know, you,
the rest of the world is right, Bill.
And you might be wrong on this one. Um,
but I missed it today.
A good friend of mine wrote in a Protean
sent me a text and I'm in podcast mode.
She sent me a text message and
asked me if I had saw the, um,
England played today.
I guess they played a great game.
And I heard Mexico had a pretty
scrappy game with the Koreans.
I heard it was getting a little nasty.
They're like, the Koreans would desperate.
Like, we don't give a fuck. You know,
we can't score unless we have the ball.
And uh, you know, I guess
Mexico's fast. That's what I know.
And I promise you this week I'm going to
neglect all my responsibilities and I'm
going to try to watch some of this
shit cause uh, it is, it is fun.
Go once every four years,
the entire world gets together to play
for an actual world championship is
pretty, that's pretty sick. You know,
I just wish I could use their hands.
You just see that one Connie
fucking jumped over the
guy and accidentally kicked
him in the face.
I mean that's gotta be like,
yeah,
kicking a guy on the ground in the face,
in the realm of like losing
your man card forever.
Like who fucked,
who does that?
Yeah.
With your shoes on,
Alicia could be barefoot,
so maybe make you foot
staying a little bit. Um,
I would be so disappointed
if I had a fucking son and
he ended up playing soccer.
First of all, I'd be happy for his brain,
but you know, if that's what he did,
you're going to frolic down the field
and jump in the air like some baby deer
and then kick somebody
in the face. Um, no,
only the guy does.
He takes out a yellow card to hit the
way they take it out and the guy just
stands up in front of the guy,
the stupid thing up in the air,
like he's bidding on a
fucking Shelby. Um, anyways,
congratulations to anybody
who won a, I got to get into
it. Sorry. I did watch the,
uh, the F one. Finally I was in town.
I got to watch her watch the French GP.
Congratulations to Lewis Hamilton.
Max for stabbing was fucking hilarious
in the press conference afterwards. Uh,
cause federal slammed into botox back.
She's going, you know, I think he needs,
you guys should tell him he needs to
adjust his style because they would given
Max Shit, you know, beginning of the
year, I forget. He took out his own teeth,
took out a, what's his face there? Um,
Daniel Ricardo and they gave
them all this shit. This does,
he need to adjust his style.
All these fucking assholes
who don't drive for a living.
So he was trashing all of them
going, you should tell Vettel. Yeah,
you should tell him he needs to adjust
his style and then he shouldn't adjusted
at all the way I didn't adjust my style
and now here I sit three races in a row
or whatever on the fucking podium.
You fucking cunts Kimmy regulated.
They kept bringing up the,
this is his 25th to 26 podium
without wedding or race.
It's like this cause fucking
Lewis Hamilton went because
Louis had was something
my kids sleeping. It's cause fucking
Lewis Hamilton winds every God damn week.
Okay.
That's like giving somebody shit.
Who played when Michael Jordan was at the
height, his powers. He never got a ring.
Nobody got a ring. You know, I've got
to ring Elijah. One would fucking,
Jordan was playing basketball and then
when he was a little out of shape the
next year, other than that,
everybody got shut the fuck down.
All right. That's what happens.
So what, what, what needs
to happen is the next, uh,
the next street great driver has to
come around. And also for one of my,
what I little know about this sport is
they got fucking get with either Mercedes
of Ferrari,
basically Mercedes,
it seems to have the fastest car out
there. Cause I think, what's this?
I think Daniel Ricardo's gonna fucking,
he's going to jump somewhere, right?
That's what they said. Um, by like both
those drives. Hey and I'll put the yanks.
How'd the Americans will
be in like six to seventh?
We've got some points and our gray cars
are overcast cars. Um,
what else did I do here?
Oh, I get back on my fucking
diet. This has been tough.
It's been tough to get back on the Diet.
I felt the cakes I fucking
eat over in France, you know,
had a couple of slip ups.
But at back to the keen wa
I'm hitting the elliptical.
Oh God.
The first two minutes of getting on
the elliptical at my age, Jesus Christ.
After that I just kind of
go numb and then it's fine.
I listen to my fucking songs
and then it's over. But, um,
I finally got the shoulder thing B and uh,
I have,
I think I have to join a
gym though because in order
to rehab my shoulder where
I can do pull ups again,
I got to do those,
those fucking lat pull downs with like
20 pounds and then 30 and work my way up
to my body weight and then I can attempt
to do like a pull up because what I did
last time when I rehabbed it was I then
got these like those help or bands,
you know, that you stand on and make the
pull up easier. But I was still, you know,
trying to pull up,
you know,
9,100 pounds with the weight and I
fucking Jack my shoulder against,
so I get to do what I don't want to do.
I've got to go join a fucking gym,
so I got to find a local
gym, not a fucking, uh,
a chain one.
Cause those are the ones that they get
your credit card and then you can't
fucking get out of it.
Ever tell you that Tamar went to Bally's.
I joined Bally's and there was
like trying to fucking lead AOL.
He just couldn't do it. They go,
okay, send in a $100 cancellation fee.
And then I sent it in and then they
go, oh yeah, yeah. But there's another,
there's another gym within
like a five mile radius.
So you can't cancel like, oh, and
I was to put the fucking, you just,
you just took $100 from me. I should have
sued the fucking shit out of him. And I,
and I didn't. So I just didn't
pay him. I just, you know, I did,
I cancelled the credit card. That
was the only way up. And it was,
it was quiet for months.
I didn't hear from anybody.
And then all of a sudden this collection
agency called me up. He was like, yeah,
and can I use William Bernie here, please.
[inaudible] Mike this, hey. They're like,
Hey, this is showing show from the
show and show collection agency. Uh,
we bought your debt from Bally's total
fitness and would like to discuss it with
you. And I just just like, well, I don't
know what the hell you did that for.
You know, I didn't pay them. What,
what the hell, but why would I pay you?
I don't even know you,
you know,
this is your business.
You actually earn a
living doing this shit,
buying debt that other
people can't fucking collect.
And then, so she was like,
you know, giving me Shit, telling me I
had to click. I'm not doing it. You know,
I go, I go, I have perfect credit.
I've paid everything. Okay.
I really don't think that someday in
the future when I go to buy a house,
they're going to be like, you know
what? We really want to let you know,
give you a couple of hundred
thousand dollars a loan here,
but you owe $300 to a gym.
And she's like, oh my God.
You know, we just had a client who just
called us up and said, please, please,
please, I have to pay off. You know,
this $400 that I owe you
because I'm trying to buy a
house and they won't let me.
And I was like, wow. I
go, that's incredible.
That's almost the exact same scenario
that I just presented to you.
It's almost like you made it up.
Right.
And then she got fucking mad at me and
then I just started hitting on her and
she started saying it was harassment and
I just gay. How old are you? You know,
you live around here, you know, you
got a boyfriend right thing. And she,
she ended up page. She got so
mad, she hung up on me. You know,
I'll probably get me to get over that.
And ever since then I've
been afraid of the phone.
Every tiny rings when shake
my cell phone's always on styling.
Um,
anyways,
what do we got 22 minutes in here?
Is it time to fucking say? And,
and you know what I gotta admit, they
just kept harassing me, harassing me.
I just got sick of it. It was only
300 bucks, so I just fucking paid him.
And,
um,
I shouldn't have, there's a couple people
that I shouldn't have paid and I did,
but I just, I didn't like
the, uh, the stress, you know,
I couldn't put it into perspective and I
just got sick of them calling me and I,
you know, I had fun with them. Shit.
Okay.
Hitting on them or are saying that I'd
gotten into some horrible accident.
That was another big one that I just said.
I don't know how many times I have to
tell you I lost my leg in a car accident.
What kind of Pete went? Oh my God, sir.
I'm so sorry to hear that. Well, are you,
this is like the third time.
I'm literally sitting here right now with
my stump elevated so I don't bleed out
because the sutures have come loose
again and here you are harassing.
This is what you do. And then they
would, you know, it was that thing. Um,
and I just ran out of ways
to have fun with them.
Uh,
and then I, I think I just finally
fucking paid him. Okay. Yeah,
I've done that a couple of times.
I gotta fucking landlord that stole
from my apartment or manage your stuff.
My pubs on the road and I came back and
uh, was on the road for three weeks.
I was on the road for so
long when I came back,
like most of the water had
evaporated on the toilet
and they had this check the smoke alarm.
So legally they could go into my
apartment when I wasn't there without my
consent because if there was a fire
it could affect the other units.
That's what they said. And uh,
all of a sudden I noticed
there was a camera missing.
They picked through my cds
was a hip hop fan. And um,
so I went down and I talked to the guy
about it thinking that the manager was
going to be like, oh my God sir, we got
to get to the bottom of this. Agent says,
I don't appreciate you coming
down to exceed you accusing me.
And he started saying all this shit,
I have the power.
He kept saying I have the power. So it
was like, oh yeah, you got the power.
I buddy. And I just stood outside the
office in anytime anybody new came.
I stood out to you for two hours. I was
like, yeah, don't run from these people.
They, uh, they stole from my apartment
and all that. That's just like, dude,
I'm a comedian.
I can do this all day.
I will be down here
every single fucking day.
And it was bullshit because the next
day I went on the road and I just,
I just didn't have it in me and um,
I should have get a,
hey, come on in here. The
lovely Nia. Everybody. Oh,
we will know. Come here. Okay.
What's going on? No, I
was just talking to them,
Bob collection agencies and all of that
type of stuff and all the crap I've gone
through. Um, I haven't had a lot of that
stuff, but you know, David's, I that I,
that time that woman called me up, they
know, knows bally total fitness and they,
and I just started hitting on her and she
got mad at me, said it was harassment.
I ended up, I ended up getting
her to hang out those up on me.
There was like the highlight. What's
the matter with you? I as Amazon,
they might teeth. Oh,
you do? Um, all right,
well I got to like
another 35 minutes here.
I'm just gonna read some advertising and
I got some great questions from people
this week.
All right.
Do you want to go get some floss instead
of just staring at me with the lick
your fingers in your mouth.
Oh, is that not sexy? Huh?
You know what? Sexy to me. You
know, it's sexy to me at my age.
Eight hours sleep that, that turns me
on. All right. All right. Listen to you.
I'd love to talk to you
while you pick your teeth.
I got to keep the momentum going.
Here we have floss.
You think you can get your fingers
between your teeth? Get out of here.
I got it. There you go.
Tenacity. Oh, we got to know a,
yeah. Okay. All right. Here we go. Jesus.
They always want to go somewhere.
You know what I mean?
He wants to fucking house and then you
get a one and then only want to do is
leave. Yeah. Boy,
fucking believable. I, when is the,
when is the guy me too thing going to
fucking happen. You know what I mean?
Reverse me too. You know, I take a lot of
these feminists a little more seriously.
If they ever bitched about something
that didn't affect their life,
you know what I mean? Yeah.
We need to fix, let me guess.
Something that affects you
is self centered. Fucking
um, all right, let's uh,
let's move on here. Oh,
and then I'm going to tell you about this,
this music festival I went to yesterday.
Definitely feeling my
age at a music festival.
Just having to stand standing too long.
Throws out my back at this
point. I know. It's my posture.
I don't need all you non
doctors out there. Just save
me. You're fucking remedies.
All right. All right. Oh, here's
something from a friend of mine. Um,
a buddy of mine,
he actually died a
couple years ago and uh,
his widow is trying to finish
a project that he started,
which is a really great idea. It's called
the, uh, the untold legends of hip hop.
And my buddy Pete coming rest his soul.
He was out there interviewing all of
these legends from the early days of a rap
music. Curtis blow, Russell
Simmons spliffs star.
And I say that right. Um, and he,
they would do these two minute little
stories talking about the early days of
hip hop and then they were animating it
and I saw some of the clips in it looked
fucking incredible and they
want to finish this thing. Um,
so they have a startup.
If you're a fan of hip hop music,
animation and all that stuff, just cool
stuff you'd like to learn about music.
The way I do the website is halo boost,
h a l o B o s t.com.
And uh, the project is the
untold legends of hip hop.
People can go to halo boosts and click
on the featured project and then you go
to the untold legends of hip hop campaign.
They donate a dollar,
whatever you can do to try and get
this thing made. It's a really,
really cool project.
And um,
from one of the great people that I've
met in this business. MMM, okay. I'll,
I'll definitely retweet the Lincoln, all
that type of stuff, so I appreciate it.
You know, if you're, you know, if you're
into it, I'm not, it's no pressure here.
All right. All right, here we go.
Ah, butcher box. Everybody. Ah,
these guys, these guys, these
guys know what they're doing here.
Put your box delivers healthy.
100% grass fed and grass
finished beef free range.
Yeah. Range. Organic chicken
and heritage breed pork
bread, bread, pork. Yeah.
The incredible quality of butcher box
meets starts with the commitment of
raising animals humanely before they
kill them and free of antibiotics and
hormones.
I gotta tell you something.
I can not say enough about
their heritage breed pork.
You got to get it all right.
You to do it in a skillet.
Sear it on both sides.
Finish the finish to the other.
Come out a little fucking
garlic butter bath.
I don't give a fuck where your
wife wants to go the next day.
You're gonna have a smile on your face.
It is fucking delish.
Each box comes with at least
nine to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24
individual size meals.
You can choose from five different box
types. I swear to God, this was around,
there'd be, you know, back in the day that
there would've been no Jeffrey Dahmer,
all beef beef and chicken, beef
and pork, mixed pork custom box.
I'm just saying because there's so much
of it, you know, I'm sorry. You know I,
I used that serial killer reference and
I know they're going to give me shit
about it was I was thinking
24 pounds of meat. Oh, Oh,
2011 pounds of meat. I was just thinking
like, you know, double up the order.
You get one of those meat freezers
in your fucking garage, you know,
you know those getting people.
So they've got all that meeting
up [inaudible] you know,
everybody else is starving to death and
you're just sitting there going like,
yeah, I don't know when helps coming.
And they're looking at you like, well,
how come you're not getting skinny like
us? Right? They're like, he's got food.
But by then the two week and you've got
all that fucking heritage breed pork and
you're all that protein, you fucking
knocked their asses out. Right?
I Dunno. And then just whenever
you think of a giant meat freezer,
you just always think of a fee.
I don't know.
You just think of somebody
chopping up a body.
Custom box lets you choose your own cuts.
Antibiotic Slash Home Hormone Free
Butcher box believes in a healthier food
system where everyone has access
to meets the way nature intended.
Free of antibiotics and hormones and
humanely raised on open. Passionate.
I got to, it's fucking delicious. Um,
put your box carefully curates the
finest selection and cuts. Look,
it's that one over there and makes it a
breeze. To customize your own delivery.
Build your own box to
exactly what you want,
a whatever you want and
what your family will love.
Choose your delivery
frequency with customization.
Customizable subscription recipes
are available on the butcher box.
Website and videos are available
to follow along on the butcher box,
youtube channel. Um, which is great.
And it says personal experience.
I told you, I already told you.
I already told you I love
the fucking pork trips. Uh,
anyways, to receive free bacon
for life plus $10 off your order.
Go to butcher bought
White Free Bacon for life.
Go to butcher box.com they probably
give you a thick slices hoping you get a
heart attacks and they got us to keep
you fucking bacon for the next five
decades. Uh, 10% off your order.
Go to butcher box.com.
Click on the big bacon banner on the
homepage and use burb you are are at
checkout. Go now. Limited
time offer. Holy Shit.
That's next level. Free Bacon
for lifetime. Me. That's
not going to be a home run.
Um, me on ds, everybody
Oh Boto to beyond days me on days free
bacon for your life to do to to me on
days beyond days.
It's just for you and not your wife.
Tell that bridge together around you're
making some bad can now leave me alone.
I wanted it fair and fucking square.
We got a bake and fucking prenup and
my balls of feeling nice and soft in my
nice tight Greg Louganis
pair of underwears. Um,
you definitely heard me
talk about me undies. Hey,
you guys heard me sing about it.
You know the fun comfy undies that feel
as good as they look to those of you
haven't tried them yet.
Listen Up.
There's a reason your balls are crying
cause all the other balls are walking
around bragging about it.
You can get incredible underwear sent
to your door with me undies meaning no
more hunting around for perfect,
for a perfect pair at a crowded store
in eventually settling for good enough.
I guess these don't make
my balls to achieve me.
Undies are made with sustainably
sourced material from beechwood trees.
How they make their underwear on a trees.
I have no idea. They're naturally soft.
Fiber makes a fabric that won't Sag.
You know,
we can your balls hanging there like
the beginning of an action movie.
Sebesta Stallone trying to reach down
and grab them or they don't ride up.
You know, like in some claustrophobic
relationship. Where is this killing?
My biological clock is ticking. He
twisted my nuts there. Trust me.
Once you put on a pair you'll get at me.
UNDIES is so sure you'll love the
first pair that if you're not happy,
well fuck they'll do whatever they
can. Hey guys, don't get look,
don't get desperate here.
They can to get it right. Uh,
get you into the right pair and if they
can't keep them and they'll refund you.
So it really is risk free to
tell your best underwear ever.
And if you're already part
of the Mandy's family,
tell your friends about it to get
there in their referral program.
This is like Scientology,
but with fucking your balls.
They'll get a discount and you'll
get a store credit. It's a win win.
Still not sure it, well me undies
has a deal for my listeners.
First Time purchasers get 15% off
their first pair of me undies and free
shipping, that's 50% off. Okay.
She didn't hear me two seconds ago plus
free shipping and a guarantee that you
and your me will be happy together.
I can't see by balls in any
other underwear except me undies.
Get you butt over to [inaudible] dot
com and treat yourself falsing into each
other, right? Me and you and you in me.
No matter how we're in the sack.
Willow,
we see each other's fucking purple face.
What color are you balls?
I always picture they were purple.
I guess they're red, right? Um,
to get your 15% off your
first pair of free shipping,
a 100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to me undies.com/ [inaudible]
that's me, undies.com/per.
I just realize how stupid
that fucking song was.
[inaudible] you and you with me? Um, oh
my God, I've got a lot of reads this week.
I got a lot of singing and do
here. Oh, dollar shave club, dude.
If you ever shower,
brush your teeth to try to make,
try to make your hair look presentable.
Here's some good news.
Dollar Shave Club has a lot of stuff to
help you out. Do you guys not much money?
I save a year on shampoo because
I shaved my fucking head.
Dollar Shave Club. Yes. Yes, that dollar,
that dollar shave club delivers
everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best. You name
it, shampoo, conditioner, body wash,
toothpaste, Hair Gel, even a wipe
that Aaliyah tush feeling tingly,
clean.
Uh,
you'll be a big fan of their amber and
lavender calming body cleanser cleanser.
After the first time you use it,
you know,
all those one wipe Charlies are basically
the poor man's per day and having used
a per day, it's, it's fuck.
I mean the fact that we still use toilet
paper over here, it's, it's, yeah.
Do you know why those Frenchies I have
and all those Manoj [inaudible] was over
there. It's because they're fucking
assholes are so God damn clean.
That's what it is.
Good luck finding a product like that
at it is store all of dollar shave club
products are made with top shelf
ingredients that won't break your budget.
You'll feel the difference.
Plus shipping is included
with your membership and is
a great way to try a bunch
of dollar shave club's
products for just five bucks.
You can get their daily essential
starter set. It comes with body cleanser,
one wipe GRE. They're amazing, but wipes.
They're world famous shave
butter and their best razor.
The six blade executive
know Shava gorilla explains,
keep the blades coming for a few more
bucks a month and add in shampoo,
toothpaste, or anything else you fucking
need. Speaking of your next month, uh,
for a limited time,
only use the code [inaudible] at checkout
to get $5 off your second month of the
club. That's Code burr@dollarshaveclub.com
to save $5 on your second month.
Join the club today. All right.
I said I got two more reads,
but I'm going to give you guys a break.
All right.
Yesterday I went to a music festival.
I went to go see the pretenders
when I was in England.
Um, the great Chrissy hine came
down with some of her friends,
some of the band members and
stuff that came down to my show.
That's the second time she's come to one
of my shows over there. So I was like,
next time you come to the u s I'm
going to your show. You got me.
I'm going and she said, cool, guess what?
I'm going to be there a few days after
he come back. So I was like, all right,
done,
done deal.
So I figured they're going to be playing
like some theater or some shit out here.
You know, I'm an old band. I'll sit down
in his seat, get myself assessed Barilla.
That'd be once in a while,
stand up and wave my fist and feel like
I've contributed as an audience member.
But now they were doing a music festival
and I get the email from her manager
and there's a map and it's to the
rose bowl. I'm like, Holy Shit.
Who the fuck is on this bill? And it
was, it was Neil Young, Jack White,
the pretenders,
the smiths,
and a bunch of other people that I'm sure
I missed in that will fucking amazing,
right? So I'm like, wow, this is going
to be, I never saw a concert at uh,
at the fucking Rosebowl. This is going to
be amazing. So, you know, I walk in there,
I walked right where it's,
you know, the Rosebowl logo.
I'm having all of these flashbacks of how
many times have been they're hammered.
Going to the rose bowl game kind of
struck me as funny to be walking the golf
course. It's a big golf course
outside the stadium, by the way.
I'm finally doing it sober.
So I'm walking in there and the first
thing I try to go into the main entrance
into the, uh, the Rose Bowl stadium.
They're like, Nah, you gotta go around,
you've got to go around. And I'm like,
well of course she got to go around.
They always make you go the
longest fucking possible way.
Why do I gotta go around?
Why don't fuck do I gotta do that?
You fucking assholes.
And then I go in there and then we
got to make a left turn and then a,
right now I'm going to
cut across the bridge,
the stadiums right fucking there and I
go to go cross bitch guns. Sorry sir.
This is one way. It's a,
it's one way for walking.
Are you worried there's going to be a
head on collision with the fuck do I have
to judge guy? You've got to go up
there right now, I'm losing my shit.
And then I'm looking around,
there's all these tents and all this shit
and all of a sudden he finally fucking
dawns on me that the concert
is not in the rose bowl.
It's all over this giant golf course.
So the whole time I'm
trying to go in the stadium,
there's nothing going on in the
stadium fucking moron. Right. And uh,
and also I'm trying to keep
my cool because somebody
told me the other day said
like, dude, you do not handle stress well.
And that of course hurt my ego. I'm
like, what are you talking about?
I don't handle stress. Well,
I'm a standup comedian.
I've performed at Madison Square Garden.
I dealt with doing five
minutes of stand up on,
on the Dave Letterman show when it was
like 30 below with the air conditioner.
Okay.
One of the most intimidating things ever.
And I was able to set aside that fucking
stress and get through it. And uh,
then the person's like, all
right, all right, Geez. You
know, just saying, you know,
and then I realized it's like,
you know,
thinking about it the next day actually
snapping again over something fucking
stupid. That of course, five
minutes later I figured out,
probably three minutes later I actually
realized that this person was right.
That I,
it's not,
I don't handle inconvenience.
Well, and then I turn it into like,
what's going on in Hawaii right now with
the lava pouring out and all this shit.
So I don't know. I've
done this so many times.
The last couple of days, you know,
except for the festival when they,
I was doing well with the stress until
they told me the bridge where people were
walking was one way.
You know,
I just all right. I mean if I even
taught, say that one more time you guys,
I'm going to lose my shit again. So
anyways, I drove in traffic yesterday.
I was completely relaxed, but I've
done this a million fucking times.
1 million times is somebody
says something to me about it.
It makes me want to change. And
then for two, three days I'm okay.
And then gradually I just go
back to the way I was, you know,
flipping the fuck out. So, uh,
I think I want to start talking about
it on the podcast the way I do with my
booze and cause that keeps my booze in
and check to tell you guys if I'm on the
wagon, I'm off or whatever. And then you
guys give me shit, a Billy booze bag,
a Billy fucking fat tits and all
that Shit. It makes me, all right,
fuck these people. I'm going
back to crushing waters. Um,
so anyways, I'm s I finally, I
figured out that this festival is,
uh, outside and now, you know,
I don't know where the fuck I'm going
and the pretenders are going to be on.
They were on in the
afternoon, five 25. Right.
Right at dusk or should've been dusk.
Different time of year would
have been dusk. Right. And, um,
I was looking like, what the fuck do I do
here? I've got to get some booze. Right?
So, you know, they're doing
these little fucking, you know,
they're not pulling home port.
So I got like two whiskeys and I'm walking
around one of my stupid Little Cup,
right. And I see this fucking
guy even older than me.
He must've been like 63.
It's actually still in pretty good shape.
But he had the long gray hair.
He had his shirt off, you know,
just that guys been going to
concerts forever, you know,
and the pretenders start up and I'm
trying to find where the uh, you know,
the best place where I can watch it.
And he starts doing like that, you know,
that like that,
that fucking hippie surfer,
spiritual white guy dancing.
It was a touch a Tai Chi in there,
you know,
he's doing that fucking dance
and you know,
it's the same dance he does to all music.
I don't even know what it is. And they
always have like this look on their face.
When you look in this smiling,
they always look at you like they have
life figured out. Like they know what,
what makes they like,
hey man, like, you know,
they going to say all this spiritual
bullshit to you that you could find on the
side of a fucking Dixie Cup. You know? Um,
then whoever that guy is, I want to thank
you. I fucking was laughing my ass off.
Uh, just a faggy had his shirt off. I got
to sit. He was still doing the, I got him,
he was still doing the pushups
so he didn't have the man boobs.
But still it's like, come on
man, these young people here,
they don't want to see
that cover yourself up.
This whole fucking pride in your
age and everything, you know,
or how you look is all well and good,
but you know,
you know what it's Kinda disappeared is
common fucking courtesy for your fellow
man. Good Lord. You know, I
just, it just blows my mind.
It really doesn't. It
doesn't. Cause you know what?
I think that guy was a baby boomer,
you know, and there's never, you know,
you know, right before the baby boomers,
sorry,
you gotta plug my headphones back in
right before the baby boomers was the
greatest generation according to Tom
Broka, they're the greatest generation.
Like I think the baby boomers in like
the most selfish and like maybe cause
there's so many of them that they had
such an influence on the culture and they
think every fucking thing that happened
during their time was just so God damn
important. They're just, I dunno, I think,
and I think that there were just so up
their own ass about themselves that now
that they're old and all wrinkly,
they just can't, they can't,
they just can't let it go. Can't
let it go. You know? I mean,
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I'm fighting aging by trying to work out
and stay in shape and eat right and all
that type of stuff. But
yeah, I stay covered up.
I have empathy for people in their
twenties. They don't want to see it.
So anyways,
um,
I go by the spiritual dancing guy and I
worked my way up as close to the stage
as I possibly can and I have
to tell you something, man,
have Chrissy hine and the
paternity is fucking murdered.
She sounded like she once
again, two weeks in a row.
I've seen great concerts.
She sounded is great as the albums
that I grew up listening to.
And um, the song she opened
with was on her, her new album.
It was just about being a loner and liking
not being in a relationship and shit.
And uh,
the lyrics are hilarious and I'm almost
a little ashamed that like how much I
relate to the song. I told her afterwards,
I was like, I fucking love that song.
Okay.
Um,
but they just fucking murdered and
she's such a Badass total rock star,
like the real deal paid her dues,
all that shit.
You just see all of that when you watch
your performance was tremendous and she
gets off stage and then next up
was Jack White. Jack fucking white.
Right. I get to see him come
out with this new lineup.
The new sound that he has. He was
fucking unbelievable day. You know,
there's another guy, if
you go see him, it's like,
when have you ever seen that guy even
remotely take a show of like half a second
off during the show?
Forget about a show.
That guy never is the
antithesis of phoning it in.
Whenever I see that guy perform live,
I always get inspired as a comedian.
Like I could be working a little harder.
I can be trying to give people
a better show here. So, um,
his set ended and um,
I walked over
to go see the smiths who I remember my,
one of my brothers listened to them.
Everybody I knew listen to better
music than I listened to in the 80s.
I just was listening to like,
I mean I listened to some good shit,
but I was listening to a lot of
fucking hair metal, you know,
which is why I missed out on Pantera and
fucking all those bands that came out
like I was, I was, I was
too far the other direction,
like a role who's has it stored
and all this. I was like,
Pauly Paul Shad, right? I'm just like,
what the fuck is this? This is, you know,
I'm as cynical as the next guy, but
Jesus Christ, that's another thing.
I started listening to that Iowa
album that slipped not shit. And like
I always liked the, uh, the heretic
day. People leave. We'll shit. I was,
it was kind of funny.
Um,
but I never like, I don't know,
it was just too much going on.
And now I'm listening to a fucking 20
years after it came out going like,
this fucking album is
unbelievable. Um, but I mean,
have, you know, there's only so
much fucking music he can lead.
You gonna miss something, right? I got
to figure out myself on some level.
So anyways, uh, I went over and I saw
the smiths and I remember that one,
that one song that crossed over that even
like a fucking mainstream Charlie like
me heard where it was a, that
stopped the med Zuno Rab, uh,
that stuff. It's up to your
future, right? Anyways,
I watched those guys that band fucking
murdered and did the impossible.
I felt it had like 10,000 white people
all dancing for their entire fucking set.
It was ridiculous. Um, how
hard they killed. And then
they ended their stair set.
Such a cool way they had this crowd do,
was sing along
as the band was started playing a
little more quiet, a little more quiet,
a little more quiet.
And the lead singer was like roasting
people in the crowd go, great job,
great job. You don't sound like good,
you sound like you've got bronchitis.
And everybody's laughing.
And then the band just sorta,
just gradually stopped playing
and the crowd one more time sang,
uh, or does it the chorus. And then
they said, thanks a lot. Good night.
It was so fucking cool.
And um,
and then Neil young starts playing.
I got to walk across the golf course
again and my back was fucking killing me
and I was jet lagged and all of that
shit. And I just, I hate to say this,
I've never seen Neil young and concert.
I just, I couldn't make it, you know,
and I had to get home,
you know,
I got a kids getting up and shit and
it's just like, I don't want to fuck it.
See Neil young standing outside
with my backbone, fucking
okay.
You know,
talking to me next to some fucking
60 year old guy doing his tight.
She fucking, hey man, dance. I
want to see this guy in a theater.
So I stood there and I
watched him play one song.
Um, so I could say, or at least most of
the first songs, he didn't even sing.
It was just like him playing guitar and
Shit. I think his experience was like,
all right,
I got to get all those people that were
just over at the Smith's time to come
over. I'm sure people's feet
hurt, their backs hurt. I mean,
he's probably doing me a favor,
but I just, you know, I dunno.
I just said to my friends,
I was like, guys, I gotta, I
gotta go home. I can't, um,
and I ubered here and it's just going
to be a thousand fucking people too.
And I just know how I'm wired.
I have to find that one way bridge
that's going to allow me to get the fuck
outta here. And I actually left, um,
during one of my favorite singers of
all time during his fucking set. Um,
but anyways, it's a great show
and all that. If you're younger,
definitely check it out. If you're
older, definitely stretch, you know,
try to keep your shirt on. Um, I
saw these two people on my God,
these two fucking whales,
these two fed people,
like one of those fat couples and they
were just asleep on their picnic blanket.
Like both in like the spooning position,
but faced opposite.
It was like a fat Yang Yang.
They would just lay in there. You
know what they look like, you know,
like at the zoo when they tranquilize
like, uh, one of those big cats,
one of those predators. And
then it's just like, all right,
now that we knocked it out,
we need to bring a fucking machine
over here to pick this thing up.
It weighs like 600 fucking pounds.
Um,
and I don't know. They,
they were oddly adorable,
like goes way like it must be fun.
You know what I mean?
Like you like those commercials
come out and you see like
dominoes or like Papa Ginos we'll
have like a fucking some deal,
like get two pizzas for seven bucks
and if you get that we'll throw in the
fucking chocolate chip cookie pie with
the whip cream and ice cream. Right.
And I always make fun of that Shit and
I always make fun of it because this a
big part of me that just wants
to order that it take the ride,
you know, have the salt fucking
take me down to the ground. Right.
And that thought is, I think
I'm going to fucking, you know,
sink into the rug like that
dude and trainspotting.
Then he started eating the fucking
cookie pie and you start coming back like
Hulk Hogan.
You know when he,
when they went to drop his hand that last
time and it didn't go down and all of
a sudden you eat the cookie thing
and you start shaking your head,
you start strutting around.
Right? But you don't,
you don't. And they get,
they get to live that life.
They get to sit there like I bet they
get one of those, you know those,
you know those big fucking couches that
on either side there's the recliner but
it's still like a sofa. I bet
they got one of those, right.
And then in the middle of it,
the thing comes down.
Remember that it was basically,
it was a fat fuck couch.
They used to make this thing before,
like the biggest loser
and everything came out.
It was like catering for people
who were fat fucks or were,
their goal in life was to become a fat
fuck because on either side of this big
couch like you,
you could pull a lever and your feet
could go up and then in the middle of this
thing would come down.
There's a place for you drinks and like
a fucking pizza and you just sit there
with you, with your girlfriend, you know,
watching the TV with your feet up,
get the AC crank and just destroy,
like just destroying the fucking
planet in your absolute like Utopia.
I mean,
I don't know if you guys believe in an
afterlife and which I've thought about,
but a lot when Vinnie past, you
know, there was all that talk about,
now he's reunited, reunited with his
brother. And I was definitely thinking,
you know, I really hope that
that happens, you know? Um,
so let's say that it does.
Okay.
If you're a fat couple and you have one
of those couches and you're watching one
of your favorite shows on Netflix or Hulu,
whatever the fuck you do,
and you sitting there with your feet
reclined eating a pizza and he got that
cookie fucking pizza thing coming next,
drinking your favorite drink,
it's just like,
what could the afterlife offer you that's
going to be any better than that if
you truly love one another. You know,
when you got the AC going, you know,
you've got your toes out. I mean, I dunno,
I think I'm selling a
lifestyle right now here.
I think it was selling
some couches. Um, anyways,
but I had a great time and uh, if you
get a chance, you know, like I said,
definitely check out that festival. And
I feel really bad that I had to leave to.
I left during Neil Young. The
fuck is wrong with me. I have to,
I have to fix that in the future
by seeing him. But like, you know,
I want to see that guy. Like,
did you ever see when he,
he did that film was at the Ryman. That's
what you want to see fucking deal yet.
Yeah. You see him at this, I'm not
trying to not sell this festival,
but I'm just saying, look, I'm old.
I need a chair. Okay. There I set it.
All right.
I used to be able to stand.
Evidently I can't any longer.
I was able to kind of work with,
work my way out of it. I know it's my
fucking posture. Posture stinks. You know,
it's all those years from fucking hate
yourself. You don't fucking slinking down.
I'm an albino. Stop
looking at me. Alright.
Indochino Indochino talk about how
every man looks better in a suit.
Well, you know, when I'm
out there trolling for cock,
you know, it's just like,
I hate to be picky,
but guys,
the sweatpants and the lazy look
isn't doing it for me. All right,
if I'm going to give it up,
I want a nice meal. Okay.
So when a guy in a suit comes along,
Indochino is the world's largest made
to measure men's wear company and as
featured in many publications,
including Gq,
Forbes and fast company,
fast company sounds like a bad sitcom.
They are old,
but they're still fucking snappy.
Uh,
they make suits and shirts made to your
exact measurements for a great fit.
Guys love the whole wide selection of
high quality fabrics and the option to
personalize all details including your
lapel lining and monogram all that's,
that's, that was, that was the sign
of a bad ass dude when I was a kid.
If you had your initials on your
sleeve of your suit, you know,
they had a company car, you know, came
home, your wife looked at the ground,
she knew who was running
shit. I mean that, that was
success. Here's how it looks,
how it works.
Sorry,
visit a showroom or shop
online@indochino.com pick your fabric,
choose your customizations,
submit your measurements,
wait for your custom custom suit to
arrive. And just a few weeks this week,
my listeners can get any
Primo Indochina,
no suit for just $379 that's
indochino.com I, n, d, O, c,
h. I. N. O. It's like China, but with an o
and it's like India with a no, right? No,
it isn't.
It's like Indonesia,
but you don't say the needs your part
then it's like China will we know.
MMM.
When entering per at checkout,
that's 50% off the regular price
for a made to measure premium suit.
How many times they can
say made to measure?
MMM,
isn't it made to measurement
plus shipping is free.
That's indochino.com Promo code and any
printing and for any premium suit for
just 379 bucks and free shipping,
incredible deal for a suit that will fit
you better than anything off the rack
ever could.
You know?
And it gives you incentive to
stay in shape once you submitted.
It's like you can't get fatter.
I gotta maintain stamps.com everybody,
the US Postal Service is an
important tool for any business.
stamps.com is the easiest way to access
all the amazing services of the post
office.
stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for any lettuce or
packages at your convenience. 24,
seven print postage for any male uh,
class right from your own computer.
The exact amount of postage every time.
Never underpay or overpay again.
I'm stamps.com saves you time
and money. There you go. Um,
which you can use to grow your business.
Buy and print official US postage
for any letter, any package,
any class of mail using your
own computer and printer.
They'll send you a digital scale that
automatically calculates exact postage
stamps.com we'll even help you decide the
best class of mail based on your needs.
No need to lease the lease.
An expensive postage meter and
there are no long term commitments.
I use stamps.com I'm got to use him
this weekend. Hopefully my post is,
get back from Ireland to fucking send
these things to Minneapolis in Detroit.
My exclusive
tour posters 50 for my age,
not my effort.
All right,
I'm going to give you 100% effort at 50
years of age and you can only get them
if you go out to the show cause I'm not
shipping them out. Again, dealing with,
hey man, like I flicking, flicking
ain't, can't find it right now.
You too can enjoy the stamps.com servers
with a special order that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a digital
scale. Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburnthatstamps.com
enter
[inaudible].
All right, we got some great emails
this week. The first one, Vinnie Paul.
Hey Bill.
By now,
I'm sure that you heard that Vinnie
Paul passed away last Friday. Uh,
much like you talked about
Malcolm Young after his death.
I feel like Vinny was another one
who just lived an amazing life.
One of the great drummers to ever get
behind the kid. I got to tell you,
like all everything that I saw on Twitter
from all these big time rockstars,
it over and over and over again.
Other than stating the obvious what
a monster, amazing drummer he was.
Everybody just talks about what a,
what a nice guy he was. Um, anyways,
he said I was too young and Penn.
Tara was leaving their mark on
the metal scene through the 90s,
so I never got to see pat terra played
live before they disbanded. However,
I did get to see Vinny play
with hell yeah, back in the day,
back in 2016 at, uh, Rockville
festival in Jacksonville, Florida.
He was quite simply incredible. Oh, this
is a cool story. I read this before, um,
the podcast, something I never
do, but I saw it said, Vinnie.
Paul said I wanted to read it.
I said,
I remember being pretty close to the front
of the stage and Vinnie was the first
band member to come up
before the show started.
When he stood up behind the drum kit,
he had this smile on his face.
Like he was just really happy to be there.
He twirled his drum
stick at the whole crowd.
A crowd saluted by putting his fist
in the air and then the madness begin.
But for most of the show,
I couldn't take my eyes off of him because
of how good he was. Oh, that's awesome.
And even though he was that good,
the biggest memory I have of him was
that he was smiling the whole show.
Like he just loved playing and see,
seeing people enjoy
themselves as much as he was.
He will be missed by more.
You will be missed by more than we know.
I don't know if that sentence
makes sense. Um, if you remember,
please crank a pan terrorists song as
loud as you can today. I'm sure Vinnie,
we'll hear it best,
which is, um, a, I, um,
best wishes in competent it said,
um,
they'll hours already listened to the
fucking shit every day and he was,
you know what, you know, it's
a great album, great live
album. Is there 101 proof?
I'm such a bad sl.
One of my favorite things
is when they play on broken.
And Phil as Phil's doing the intro video.
Vinnie's already counting in the song,
just how tight they were.
Always our world shore route
or north called our broker.
[inaudible] of course job brown
Al Bag. I get paid. Oh, alright.
Coco the gorilla.
Oh,
I saw this too at fucking
sweetheart of a gorilla.
Um, did I did the bit above
a hey bill, I saw you,
you live last year and I love you special.
We talk about teaching
gorilla sign language.
I was watching clips of cocoa interacting
with people like with flee from the
Chili peppers and Robin Williams.
I watched those.
I was still nervous and I just saw a flea
laying down and there's like a fucking
gorilla right next to him. Um, I dunno,
I get you're shooting the shit with it.
You can kind of, I dunno. Um, um, the,
it made me nervous.
You know,
I wonder if it made me nervous just
because I'm such a big fan of flee and I
didn't want to see anything happen to him.
Like it was a bass player from a band.
I didn't give a shit about them.
And if they go, look at this guy,
this could get interesting. Um, anyways,
it was, it was charming as hell.
I was wondering if you ever set down with
cocoa, if ever given a chance. Well, no,
not after the bid I did. They
probably, this guy's a fucking asshole.
You could have asked him why the chicken
crossed the road and wait for a chuckle
or tried to explain humor to him.
MMM.
Five a sat down with that gorilla.
I in that thing, actually,
if that wasn't a party trick, if it
actually knew how to do sign language,
I imagine it would sign to me.
You seem nervous.
Okay.
And hours and back. Yeah.
Well you're a fucking gorilla.
Um, anyways, kids show recommendation.
Um, hey there Billy barnacle
balls. I want you to, I want,
if you want a show to watch with
your girlfriend, checkout. Okay.
I thought it said octo nuts, like
something with eight balls. Octo nuts.
Is it an octopus in outer space?
I watched it with my girls and kids and
I actually learned some stuff. All right,
well that was about as vague as the,
uh,
what was it that was that movie way back
in the game, the silent game or the,
there's something game or
the something or other.
Remember David Spade had that joke?
I'm going to tell the time.
I'm going to tell you guys the secret of
the crying game and he goes over rated.
Yeah.
All right. Hair transplant, depression.
Oh No. Hey old freckled Dick.
I'm a 21 year old man. I recently
got a hair transplant surgery. Well,
you must be a hairy motherfucker,
man. You went bald that are soon. Um,
the surgery went great.
Good. Good for you.
But I now hate that I have a
huge scar in the back of my head.
I don't they do it now where they just
vacuum the shit out so you don't have to
have that smile on the back of your head.
He goes,
every time I cut my hair,
you can see it.
Could you give me some advice
on what I should do? Well,
yeah,
don't cut your hair so fucking short.
Now that you've get back on top of your
head, grow your hair out, you'll be fine.
That was an easy one.
What are you doing?
You got hair plugs yet?
I'm hacked the back of your head.
Then he got fucking hair plugs and now
you're shaving your head down to the
point where you can fucking see it
anyways. What was the point? Um,
I don't know. I would just, I guess I
would just grow my hair out a little bit.
I don't think it has to be
that long to cover the scar.
As long as it's long enough
that you can't see your scalp,
I think he should be all
right. Right. Anyways,
pit bull problems,
dear g OBA RSF Hasif oh,
Billy. Easy shave butter. Oh,
facilities face right now.
That's easy. Facilities easy. I Dunno,
I have no idea. I suck at that
shit. As he former pitbull owner,
I'd like to ask your advice on a problem
I'm having. My wife comes home from, uh,
my wife comes from a large family and
they get together at her parents every
month for Sunday dinner and family
hangouts. The last two times.
My brother in law has brought is recently
a duck is recently adopted pitbull.
It's a rescue dog and he doesn't think
it was abused or used to fight because
it's so good with kids. According to
him it's a large family. So there,
there are about 50 kids ages
three to 11 running around.
And my four year old daughters,
one of them,
she loves dogs and likes
this one in particular,
but both times he brought my dog.
My daughter has come running to me in
tears because it got over excited and
jumped onto her too rough.
Well that's the thing about pities man,
they just a big fucking
awesome ball of muscle.
And when I used to wrestle with my dog,
I used to have to lay my neck
over the top of his neck.
He had to get inside because she was
lightening quick and she would turn around
and hit her head was like a wrecking ball,
godliness,
that fucking dog. I still get to
see her every couple of months,
but I really miss that.
Um, anyways, he goes,
I don't hate dogs, but I don't love them
either. And I don't trust pitbulls. Well,
you have to validate all of
that. Okay. To be quite honest,
I'm kind of afraid of them.
I'd never forgive myself if
something happened to my daughter.
If I say something to my inlaws,
I looked like a killjoy asshole,
but I'm too stressed out to enjoy the
family gathering because I'm hovering over
a constantly.
So my wife's response has been to treat
me like I'm overreacting and dismissed
my concerns.
It's bothering me so much.
I've considered just keeping
my daughter home next time.
But am I making too big a deal about this?
I think it's a recipe for disaster.
I don't feel like it's my place to tell
my brother in law to keep it at home and
my wife's not supporting me.
Please tell,
please let me know if you have
any ideas. Uh, may see ava.
Got to fair for two. Thank you. Thank you.
And I imagine that
saying go fuck yourself.
Um,
I know advise and go to is
you [inaudible] all right.
Anyways. Uh, I would say this dude,
you have to like,
if that's what you're feeling,
you don't have to tell anybody
to leave a dog home on it.
You just have to communicate
this to people. All right?
Say you don't hate dogs,
you don't love him either and you
don't, I don't trust pitbulls. Okay.
And just tell them that rather than
be like, keep the fucking lunatic.
Just tell them that.
All right.
And I would sit down with
your wife and say that,
you know,
I don't feel like you're
hearing me all right.
She's my daughter and I'm concerned
and I have to be honest, you know,
if you had these concerns,
I would listen to them and you're not
validating what I'm feeling and it's
really bothering me and I can't
enjoy when I go over there.
I don't want to be this killed joy,
but I'm hovering over our kid and I just,
you know, it's bothering me.
You married me, you love me.
I'm telling you something's bothering me.
We need to talk about it.
You can't go there because that'd be up
and you fucking talk to me about this.
That's what I would do.
Keep it in the register.
I was just in all right.
And don't stop having the conversation
until there's a solution that you're
satisfied with. It should
daughter. Okay. And uh,
you know, dogs are abused, right?
And if a dog snaps, you know,
it's a bad thing around a kid.
And then when you have a pit bull, the
thing about a pitbull is its capability.
You know what I mean? Some dogs that like
a little water pistol and other dogs,
or like a fucking bazooka.
That dog is a bazooka.
So not saying the breed is bad,
I'm just saying if somebody fuck
that dog up and it does snap,
the results are,
you know,
gonna be really bad. So, and you
have to address that that's being,
or you're being a responsible parent and
these people need to listen to you and
a, you need to speak up. You've got to
stand up for yourself there, buddy. Boy,
it's my advice. All right, good
luck. Okay, lady, lady manager.
Crossing the line.
Dear bill or William Butler,
will you call yourself below?
Hello Wall?
I'm a 23 or 23 year old lady who
just started working in an office.
I love when women write in. It's always
guys, God bless you for right now,
who just started working in an office
for a big company. It's a boring job.
But while I figure out what to do with
my life after graduating, it's all right.
Well there you go. That's not bad. You're
23. You get your whole life ahead of you.
Uh, I got promoted with the recommendation
from my former manager at this 40
something year old woman who
I thought was quite nice. Uh,
now she's not my manager anymore,
although she still senior to me.
She has been a little inappropriate with
me. And after an office Christmas party,
me and my colleagues went to a club.
Uh,
I came out of the club
bathrooms and she was waiting.
She didn't even come with
us. Well, that's weird.
She waved me over to sit next to her
and asked me if I was gay. I said, no,
I'm not. And she went fine. It didn't
speak to me for the rest of the night.
All right, well she needs a better
opening line that she's a little blunt.
You know, she's in business. She
got right down to brass tacks. Uh,
she said I was a bit uncomfortable with
the question because what business is it
of hers? Oh, I thought she was gay.
She wanted to hook up with you.
Cause what business is it of her?
So I told one of my work
pals what had happened. Uh,
they had been at the company longer than
me went. Wow, you're her new one then.
Oh boy.
Oh,
G G.
I asked them what they meant and a guy
said, well, I may look at her right now.
She's filming you and
she, Sarah enough. What?
Ensure enough she was, she
was, when I turned around,
she hid her phone as I was a little
bit too drunk and under the influence.
I was already paranoid. So I decided
to leave because I felt so gross.
Since then,
she's pulled me aside to say that I
looked delicious and scrumptious oh,
what a crape. Whenever she
sees me at the end of the day,
she taps her cheek and demands that kiss.
Oh yeah, what the fuck is this per
she and, oh, that's [inaudible].
That's like a gross relative.
She asked a girl who works for me to
take pictures of me and to send it to her
when we're at a pub.
I consider myself and assertive girl,
but there's something about
how public about her actions,
which makes me so timid,
so I go along with it.
Now I'll do that.
You think you would think that
because she's not my manager anymore.
Now that I've been promoted,
it wouldn't be a problem,
but it is because my new
manager is their best friend.
I don't want to cause a riff in this new
job, but it's really stressing me out.
Am I within my rights to tell her to stop?
Absolutely. You are. How do I tell it?
Is that no,
I don't want to kiss her on the cheek
every time I see you without looking like
a bitch.
Listen,
the way you're looking
at this is fucking crazy.
You're, you're sitting here looking at
like how like you're being an asshole.
You're not. This person is
completely out of line. She said,
a few of my friends thinks it's a funny
situation, but I don't, and if you don't,
then it isn't. You've got to validate
that if this was a male manager,
he'd be reported. I love your stuff
so much and I wish I could come back.
You'd come back to Glasgow someday
from a fellow fellow pasty redhead.
Um, all right, dear
fellow fucking pasty. Um,
yeah,
this is what you gotta do. She
asked for a kiss. You tell him no,
and I just stare at, I mean, listen,
you have all the fucking power in the
world or if you just want to go to the
manager and say,
listen,
I don't want to cause some me
to scandal or any of that shit.
Can You keep this weird old fucking
bag away from me and tell her to be
professional? I mean, that's
the proper way to do it.
Those are the proper channels,
but I have to
do it that way. Do it that way. Okay.
Do it that way. And, and, and
document that this has been happening.
You have all these witnesses about them
filming her and all of this type of shit.
If they ever tried to fire you, I mean
that you don't have a problem at this.
This kind of thing needs to stop and uh,
you know,
in a perfect world you'd go to her,
cause I don't like that
whole telling on a thing,
but that's how the business
world works. Um, you know,
in a perfect world when she fucking
goes like pointed to or cheek. Yeah,
that's right where you should punch her.
Yeah.
Fucking blast or right in fucking face.
Yeah. I mean if you're ever at a
bar again and she's doing that Shit,
I would fucking dump a drink
right over her fucking head.
Like that's just creepy
behave. I would just, mmm,
you got to stop this Timothy. Cause if
you're timid someone like that, it's,
it's gonna. It's like a magnet.
They're going to go right towards you.
You've got to step up to her and
tell her what a fucking creep she is.
And if I catch you take
a video or, or, or, uh,
pictures of me or any of this
other fucking creepy sexual
shit that you're doing,
I'm going to report you,
okay?
And you think you're going to get together
with you, fucking manage your friend.
Okay? All I gotta do is go on social
media and your fucking world is over.
The fuck is my phone.
What the fuck is mine anyways, but don't
do that. That's all anger. Listen you,
but you know,
you are,
you seem like a really like overly
nice people pleasing person at 23,
which I was where you're like, is
it me? That the way I'm dressing,
that's attracting this, it's
not you. It's that person. Okay?
So whatever the fuck I said
before I got upset, uh,
just go, listen, I got an
issue and don't be listening.
I don't want to come to the family.
They go in there fucking flat footed
and look right at that person and say,
listen,
I got an issue with her.
She's coming at me in weird sexual ways
and I'm getting sick of it and I'm sick
of it. I want to come here and go to work
and do a great job. I don't need that.
Okay. I would like to file an
official report on her harassing me.
Okay. And that's the deal. And I
want it to stop. It stops right now.
Are we clear?
That's it.
That's it. There's no, don't go
in there fucking hat in hand.
You don't have to be a, can't
just go in and just say, look,
this is happening and it
needs to stop immediately.
Okay. Well, I mean,
what if she just flashes your
kitchen? You, I mean, what
the fuck he going to say?
You can't say that it's over. Right?
All right. Good luck to you. Okay.
Stay out of the sun and the rest of you,
uh,
go fuck yourselves and I'll check
in on you on Thursday rested piece.
Vinnie.
Paul.